[Music]
I want to talk about Sunday's episode so
spoiler alert if you haven't watched
Sunday's episode episode 12 we're gonna
talk about it okay
because there is a giant reveal at the
end of the episode that Lorca is in fact
from the alternates parallel universe
which is wild and I think some fans are
speculating it but it's confirmed how
long did you know that information for
and what was your reaction we knew
pretty early on that like the main arcs
of each character I was gonna let you
see toes but we knew that because you
know that sort of what sets the whole
sort of series knowing Jason was you
know like a bad guys it was it was just
a fun it's fun to know that he's playing
that it was just great to watch
understand yeah because the show kicks
off and you're like he's a bad guy
and then you're like no but what does
this reveal mean for the discovery crew
going forward there's I mean how many go
left now yeah three more EPS yeah yeah
everything comes to a head in the crate
I mean cuz everyone's got their own
everyone's gotten a brilliant arc in
this there's more literally coming to
head him in 15 basically it gets what
1300 then he gets crazy like I don't
give anything away but because it's
really good it's only three weeks ok so
you can wait it out well Michelle Yeoh
is back sort of ya know I'm trying to
think have you had a scene with her in I
don't think we've seen that no no that
one yes we saw in the episode that
Laurel seemingly undoes the the effects
that you have gone under how will that
impact her oh yeah it's very stretchy
because you know I was saying it was
like a 4-way loved love triangle it's
just three into three bodies so it's
like one of them had to give and
unfortunately Vulcan Laurel can you know
can continue this one day had anything
new you know both of those relationships
equally justifiable I think you know
they were on their own journeys and
but then also he's got him and Michael
as well as Tyler and Michael but that's
not looking great but you know they just
needs to you know sort some stuff out
but the roads gonna be you know it's
horrible for her just you know One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest kind of yeah